hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're
starting our coverage of the 2019 a US
chess championship gonna be held for the
next two weeks March 20th through April
1st held at the st. Louis Chess Club
where many of the top US tournaments are
held it's a 12 player round-robin so the
top Americans have come together to
battle it out to see who is the champion
these tournaments are always great
because if one gives us an opportunity
to see a lot of American players who we
don't cover in other tournaments who are
very very strong grandmasters it also
gives us an opportunity to see some of
the youngsters coming up in the game
previous junior champions highly rated
in the world they take an opportunity to
go against some of the more known people
that the Fabiano's the Wesley shows the
Nakamura and seeing them battle against
the top Americans is always fascinating
so in today's game we have two
competitors why it's gonna be played by
Timur Gotti EV he's 31 years old if
you're not familiar haven't heard much
about him
he's a blindfold master he's he's a
grandmaster that holds the world record
for the most consecutive or most
simultaneous blindfolded chess games at
48 that is a ton of games to be playing
at the same time blindfolded
his opponent playing the black pieces 18
years old so one of the youngsters
Jefferson we've covered games from him
in the past
he was the 2016 US Junior champion so we
covered some of his matches from 2017
where he did extremely well in this
tournament but he's also the highest
junior rated player in the United States
third highest junior rated player in the
world so this is the tournament this is
the first round so we will go ahead and
get into it
Timur starts out with Knight to f3 met
by pawn d5 and then Ponzi for this is
the ready opening usually just met with
pawn to e6 getting into the Queens
gambit declined lines pawn to d4 and if
you just walked up to the board and
didn't see my magical yellow error here
you may think that this was a normal
Queens game of the climb line didn't
even arrive from the ready opening but
Geoffrey had other ideas said I'm not
playing that you've seen that before I'm
gonna play pawn to d4 change things up
Timur said
okay that's fine with me I'll go ahead
and close my eyes and make the move of
pawn to b4 opening up for the bishop
become to be to attack in these dark
squares in the center or even Queen to
a4 at some point hidden check that
Geoffrey has to be worrying about poor
the rest of the game Bishop comes down
here to g4 attacking and pinning down
the Knights and the Knight to e5 we're
already at a book line so there's no
theory they can go back to they haven't
studied lots of Grandmaster games with
this it's it's a novelty and so this is
why I like these tournaments you see
these openings you're not used to seeing
so very interesting to see how they
approach the games and then play from
here cuz it really is okay neither of us
know how this game is gonna go who is
the better chess player Bishop comes
back to f5 and then pawn to e3 now black
is protecting this we doesn't
necessarily have to take this pawn he
can if he wants to but instead Geoffrey
plays Knight to f6 says yeah I'm just
gonna continue to belt my pieces like
normal see what my opponent does and
then timur comes out just swinging he
plays pawn to g4 now watching this you
really get a sense that both sides are
going for it you know why it's not
looking to castle on either side of the
board two pawns on the the Queen side b4
and c4 so he's not pushing on that side
pawn to g4 is extremely aggressive move
from and yes he has his night here on e5
and his queen on d1 both defending this
square but Geoffrey does have some good
options that he can go to here but
starts to put a lot of pressure and says
how do you want to continue because I'm
going all attacking I'm not playing
defense at all there's two main lines
that I see as I analyze this first one
would be Bishop to e4 this is defended
by the knight here it's attacking the
rook it's really gonna be messing up the
position from white even more if you
know rook to g1 okay clearly can't even
attempt to castle but this is still a
central bishop that White has to deal
with or even pawns who f3 this is just
pushing the pawns even further up the
board and I think that's a fine place
for black two being because he still has
a very solid pawn structure up here I
think the better
actually is just the pond takes here on
e3 this has so many different options
for white to fall into and play in
correctly let's say that white made the
biggest mistake and says okay if you
want to take my pond I'll go ahead and
take your Bishop right here that looks
like a free piece unfortunately it's not
the pond can take on f2 this is going to
be check the king can take here on f2 it
doesn't really matter if the the King
comes to e 2 it's still going to be bad
can't Queen down here to a d4 after the
the King moves here can just gobble up
material here on e5 you can see it's
also attacking the rook here on a1 so
maybe the pawn up to d4 and then we see
another piece fall here on f5 so
definitely not going to be a good move
to go ahead and take that Bishop that
would be Bates but maybe they instead
play we see the pawns take here on a3 ok
well now the the Queen's gonna come down
the King captures the Knights gonna take
that material here on g4 maybe the
knight takes the bishop takes here check
Bishop takes or comes here to e2 and
then the bishop comes back here this is
gonna be a fine position you can see
black is up a pawn in material I think
things are gonna go completely fine for
black in this position now the other way
instead of the pawn not taking here
let's say the pond takes here on III
just completely opening up the King side
of the board now and then Bishop to e4
it's hacking the rook rook to g1 I think
this is gonna be a fine spot for black
to be in equal sides as far as material
here but black just is much more solid
as far as his pawn structure right here
can really be flexible as far as how he
wants to continue so that's the best
option I think in the game Geoffrey made
a good move I just think that taking
here on e3 was more optimal but he
decided to go ahead and play bishop here
to e4 attacking the rook here on h1
Timur pushes forward with pawn to f3
Bishop comes back to g6 Bishop b2
attacking this pawn in the center of the
board decides to go ahead and take with
his pawn here on e3 after the pawn
captures Knight to d7 so if you look at
this Geoffrey has the opportunity to
bring his queen down here and take on d1
but he has the solid structure he knows
his opponents is not gonna be castling
so he wants to keep his most powerful
pieces on the board because as soon as
he exchanges off the Queen's he really
loses the advantage that he has over his
opponent right now if no King safety so
he doesn't want to come down instead he
decides yeah I need to shut down this
exchange right away he plays Knight to
d7 so good heads-up play from him now
the knight takes on g6 and then after
the recapture here don't want to
recapture with the F pawn you can see
this isolated pawn here on the e-file
not exactly what black wants to be doing
so instead decides to go ahead and take
with this pawn here from h7 here to g6
opens up for the rook to control semi
open file on the H file but now we do
have white with a bishop pair so that's
one thing Timur has going for him he
really needs to start pushing his pawns
up the board putting a lot of pressure
on his opponent Jeffry needs to at some
point counter-attack to start blowing up
the center of the board can maintain his
strong pawn structure and he should be
pretty well off Knight to c3 continued
development pawn to e6 opening up the
door for the bishop you get involved
into the game attacking this pawn here
on b4 pawn c5 stopping that but also
just gain space
cutting off some of the squares that
Geoffrey can go to pawn c6 does not want
to have this pawn pushing up any further
pawn to g5 pushing forcing at the knight
to move knight over here to d5 we do see
an exchange in the board and then the
pawn recaptures on d5 still maintaining
a very solid pawn structure pawn to f4
so the same thing White's making sure he
has a solid Pont ruksar on the King side
of the board and then Queen to e7
attacking this backward pawn here on e3
white moves his queen
Pierre 2d to making sure he defends the
square here on e3 and then rook to h4
just trying to get this piece to be
extremely aggressive in the big game
Queen over here to f2 still defending
the square also attacking the rook here
on h4 and then the Queen comes down here
to e4 so hey if you're gonna attack my
rook I'm gonna attack your rook as well
why it does have to be careful although
it looks tempting to go ahead and take
the rook here on h4 that would be a bad
move because not too worried about the
rook falling on h1 needs to really be
worried about the Queen coming over here
to b4 check and then the bishop is going
to fall maybe King up here to f2 Queen
down here to be to check the rook
looking to fall as well maybe the Bishop
to e2 blocking the king also defending
this rook here on a1 with the other rook
but then the knight takes on c5 you can
see we now have a passed pawn in the the
C file putting a lot of pressure in this
Queen over here on h4 just kind of
hanging out by himself so not the
recommended way for white to go about it
and so in the game decided to go to just
play pawn to a3 now Geoffrey decides hey
I want to go ahead and take your rook
here on h1 my Queens fairly alone right
now I don't have to worry about too much
from an attacking standpoint but after
that now it is safe for Timur to go
ahead and take with his own queen on h4
there's no threat the Geoffrey has to go
ahead and put white in check pawn to a5
starting to attack on the Queen side the
board Queen comes back here to f2 so
blocking some of the squares that black
would want to go to pawn takes here on
b4 we do see an exchange on the Queen
side the board with the rooks work comes
and takes here on a1 is then recaptured
by the bishop here on a1 queen sinner's
back here to e4 and then Bishop up here
to c3 so if we look at both sides of the
board they are equal in material we do
you see white has the better bishop
here here black never ended up castling
on either side of the board this had
double pawns on the G file all in all
I'd say both sides are fairly even I
would give a slight edge to black only
because he has more aggressive Queen
here on e4 and also just putting a lot
of pressure on this backward pawn here
on e3 Geoffrey now decides to go and
start attacking on the Queen side of the
board plays pawn to b6 King here to d2
takes material on a c5 and the
interesting move of pawn to b5 so just
wants to give up a pawn in material yes
that pawn is gonna follow the bishop
comes up here to b5 but he pretty much
gave up a pawn when he did not need to
so after that pawn to c4 I'm not sure if
he recognized this move but this is
blocking off a lot of squares from white
side of the board and from here things
continue to get weirder Queen over here
to e2 Queen down here to b1 attacking
the bishop and then Bishop takes on d7
now I feel like one of the benefits that
white has is he had the bishop hair and
he was down upon a material so one thing
you really don't want to be doing is
just exchanging material down because
you have a deficit that's just gonna
increase in favor for your opponents but
he decides to go ahead and take with his
Bishop here on d7 King recaptures queen
up here to g4 check and then Queen to f5
there's always these small moves that
you're not sure if they see but after
the Queen here to f5 it really blocks
any of the the threats that white had
here so not sure exactly everything he
wanted to get out of that exchange here
on d7 but now we see pawn to h3 King to
c6 so just getting that involved into
the game recognizing that the the white
queen over here can't do too much it's
blocked behind his own pawn structure
right here and the Queen here on f5 so
we have black over here keeping his King
on the
light squares he knows his opponent only
has the bishop on the dark squares so
that really becomes kind of a piece not
doing too much if he never puts his
pieces on the black squares King over
here to e to King to a b5 Bishop up here
to a d4 and now the exchange on the
board white now has his own double pawns
on the G file and you can see a passed
pawn here on C for black now has a
massive advantage in the game not too
much going great for Timur he's just
playing defense at the moment King to b4
just pushing on the queenside pawn up
here to e4 yeah I'm gonna go ahead and
take that material just giving up more
material to black King to a d2 bishop
down to a c5 says I don't even care if
you want to go and take material here in
g7 that pawn is irrelevant in the game
that's not what the game is about right
now
so Bishop takes on g7 King down here to
B 3 and then pawn up to f5 again doesn't
really matter what's going on the King
side of the board decides to go ahead
and play pawn to e3 not too worried
about even giving up material right here
and then the King over to e - trying to
stop this but it defended by the bishop
right here now the King can easily get
involved into the game something like C
to start pushing forward with the pawn
as well very very difficult for white to
continue we did get one more move in the
game Geoffrey played pawn to c3 team of
recognizing this is not going to go well
I can't I can't just give up my bishop
here on c3 and if I don't I am going to
eventually lose my opponent can easily
get a queen in the game where I'm gonna
have to give up too much material I
can't overcome so Geoffrey does take the
victory he's only won to get a win in
round 1 so he sits atop the standings
pretty good showing for the 18-year old
we'll see if he can continue over the
next couple weeks to have a strong
showing but hopefully you guys are
excited about this tournament this is
one of my favorite tournaments all year
to come
so we will have as much coverage as
possible over the next two weeks again
thanks for watching and I'll see you
guys tomorrow in a round two of the u.s.
Chess Championship 2019 in st. Louis